are you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby there's no
kidding around here kylie jenner and her
daughter stormy know how to take a joke
are you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby
here's the back story a tick tock
creator who goes by the name stormy baby
has amassed over a million followers by
impersonating the famous mother-daughter
duo me and stormy
literally just went to
a store
storm
storm stormy
do you want to do something crazy uh-huh
oh
like go to a car wash
really
okay
but the sound that took tick-tock by
storm or should we say stormy are you
kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby
so when kylie and stormy decided to give
it a shot yeah the tick tocker freaked
out writing in the caption i am dying i
love you kylie are you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby
and when kylie and stormy aren't killing
time on social media they're making
memories which kylie of course
also shares online i love it last month
kylie took stormy on a shopping spree of
her own makeup products
and in may stormy absolutely stole the
show when she joined her mom and dad on
the red carpet at the billboard music
awards trev are you enjoying your family
night out
kylie are you enjoying mom and dad
nights out hi stormy
but what fans really want to see is
stormy in action as a big sister kylie
baby number two number two
congratulations thank you
as fans of the famous fam know kylie and
stormy's dad travis scott welcomed their
second child a boy back in february the
couple initially named their little one
wolf but later revealed they were
dropping that name but not a wolf why
not wolf
and
what is the name wolf was never on our
list okay um
it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still
i just wasn't him okay so it wasn't
against anything to do with the name it
just wasn't him and i get that you know
i get that so do we have a name no
okay we have we have some um
we have some maybe really strong options
but we haven't officially changed we
have some placeholders so before i
officially change it i just want to be
sure you're seeing that little
personality
and while we wait for kylie to make that
announcement we're sitting tight also
anticipating the first pick of her baby
boy
so far we've only seen tiny glimpses
like this one she shared on june 19th of
his feet
here's hoping one day we'll see stormy
and her brother giggling together on
tick-tock are you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby
[Music]
you